how's it going bro my name is welcome
back to great it's new horror mode that
just came out and in the last episode we
stopped
here I don't know what's going to H
hey hey let me see your face
no that son of a [__] what the hell was
he doing
there more in
Heavens well it's locked and I can't
open
it that suckss at least we have a key
now I guess
I what was
that [__] who's in that
truck boxes for me can't you see I like
to pee because I watch way too much
Glee
every
whoa I feel like someone is watching me
I'm not going to ride this must resist
riding them well what the we got the key
and it goes to so here all right all
right I got it yeah that's how we roll
that's how we get to oh
[__] okay we're fine we're fine we're so
fine okay we're not fine the lck is down
okay that's cool all the doors are
locked you know what that's fine it
could just be like a standard procedure
that in the creepy area uh all oh [__]
we can't go there [__] me oh what the
[__]
girl
mom mom what the [__] are you doing up
[__] me don't not a [__] not you Mom
that's disgusting banana oh it's Gallia
okay [__]
this okay that is [__] up right
there girl hold up hey Michael how you
that oh
okay hey there you are oh that's nice
what what the hell did my mama do that
my mom would never do that no she
wouldn't she would have I don't know
yeah she okay what is this is that a key
and a some wallet
maybe I don't know Pokemon game boy
maybe no well I'm taking this don't you
dare come alive if I take this this key
is l a for the back exit I've got to
hurry I got your key stupid why do I
have to hurry why can't I go closer to
him
well
B okay back door don't understand back
door what is
this and I hope that piece by Ian re got
your emotions all stirred up I know I
did so for you just tuned in you are
listen F local radio F local
DJ DJ okash it's
really radi next up
is with very good very
good he wears the hat that he wants
that's a it's
Swedish I hope he's going to sing in
[Music]
Swedish I can't make sense of
this
[Music]
what the hell
is okay hey
[Music]
come
what he said that for SK correct this
not bad he said he will correctly show
his dick that's nice thank you for that
song yeah that was good well they said
we have to hurry so I guess we shouldn't
[__] around too
much first sk correct this not this is
where where we were I'm an idiot I am
aware don't worry about it don't even
worry about
it ah is this the back door
girl well maybe
here I know this is where we came from
don't
worry maybe there's like a door in here
yeah exit all right
cool well [__] me this door then that's
how I roll that's how I get to the Le
this okay you can't see this text but
I'm going to read it anyway it made my
day I made my way through the majority
of block 12 I continued on determined to
find someone or something up ahead was a
construction side abandoned some time
ago the
descrip shells of half buil buildings
stood around me the hairs on the back of
my neck began to rise I felt like I was
Batman how the heck did we come from a
double door oh I guess we came from here
okay don't even worry about it okay
worry I'm a little worried what the hell
was
that what in the
earth okay this is graffiti walls that's
fine that's a creepy hole what is this
althor personnel
only
ah what is this oh you can jump over it
cool can we go in here
ah well well that means we're
[__] oh oh hell no
ow
ahep very
nice
hey very nice to
beet okay it's good to be back PE good
to be back oh who you talking with who
are you talking with damn I feel badass
with this do not
cross don't even worry about it don't
even get out of my way get out get up my
side oh who are you looking at bottles
huh H hey that's right bottles that's
right I really don't think I should be
here well don't worry about it P don't
even worry about it don't even worry go
down wait
wait
okay what is up with this
place this is kind of creepy
that's fine creepy as
it's
hello I feel really like I'm being
watched It's go get
up w die
whoa
what I don't know about this one don't
go closer hey don't don't don't worry P
it I'm scouted don't go
he hey hey hey h how you doing you have
you have nice
shoes don't trust their py really nice
sh you see if you compliment ladies on
their shoes they won't kill you I know
that really nice Sho he hey he you hey
py don't talk to me don't talk to me
what is
this
it's dead don't even worry about
it well that was a waste of
time what are you doing
here huh what are you f to try
[__] I didn't think
so what the hell I told you you had nice
shows what else do you want from me well
where's the exit oh here it is well I
I'll see you later
I see you later alligator on that's a SC
what are you
doing hey Patty don't look at me like
that don't even think about
it hello hey that's a cute
catch the hell is going on here
two I can't break
themy what should I do kill everything
baby all right you you said
man can't open
it hate you I hate you
guys [__] what the [__] I thought I saw
something that scared the [__] out of
me I didn't even see something I'm
stupid I'm scaring myself here
okay open the bottles finding batteries
that's cool I didn't even know I had I
relied on
batteries
okay there's a shut up shut
up there's nothing here there really is
nothing
here
[Music]
it oh [__] I hate I
hate ah which way I don't even know
let's go over here we're fine oh nice
nice [__] a dead end don't even worry
about it we let's go to the other place
doesn't even
matter okay what's going on here
seriously
why why did he do
that okay we're
fine uh guess we got to go up here I
keep thinking I see someone and it
freaks the [__] out of
me oh don't look down py
ah don't even worry about it ah don't
look [__] my [__] shut
up that was close that was so close okay
we're good shut up I guess we got to go
down
here bring it [__] ow ow I hit my
head oh [__] okay don't worry about it
don't even worry about
it a [__] that's a snake Ah that's a
snake Okay we're fine let's go in here a
shut up looks like I found a way out yes
H what is this I closed the building for
the working hours I don't want strangers
walking around if you want to leave for
something the K is on the top of my
locker the K take the the the K take if
you want something D it's on top well
the shir's Hing
here if you want something then looking
top of my locker top of top of my locker
bit top of my locker if you want
something then it's on top of my locker
the top of my locker what the top of my
locker
girl on top of my lock found it on top
of if you
want top of my lock my
[__] my lock
[Music]
sorry sorry sorry about this let's
go ah exit exit exit exit exit they just
make you go through hell for no good
reason I mean like extra
[__] nailed it the cluster of imposing
mry and the dark Eloy finally gave away
the familiar Lights of the city after
catching my breath I instantly began
walking towards work I was thinking for
help lacking any other options even in a
bright light Street Shadows seemed to be
creeping around the edge of my vision my
imagin turning into horrific of without
worldly manace I felt hemmed in as if
something were directly me directing me
a path that I did not necessarily Want
To
Tread let's play a little more nothing
really happened in this episode
finally no more ducts or Dusty rooms
yeah yeah yeah F you w Bang by
bye all right Co Bakery Saturday special
what what the hell can I just read the
menu
come back
here what the
frer what is he
doing [__]
off what the hell did I ever I have pep
now at
least all right what is this all this
trash is why the houses are so Dam
cheaper around here well who the hell
would buy a house here you got to be
[__]
stupid what is this give me all of it
don't try to hide for me Barrel that's
try to ow don't squeeze my ass minute M
it don't even make that anymore they
don't even make minute me anymore they
don't even make
he I'm claustrophobic let me
out why what
F what the [__] was that I don't
know
I don't
know I don't know shut up okay that's
end it there I can B if you enjoyed
subscribe come and it helps out a lot
and I'll see you next
episode all right
cool there it comes there it
is for
now why I got 91% secret alien mother
ship is exploding oh no the alien Mother
Ship I just want to tell you
this is so beautiful this is such a nice
moment